foreign
[__] Broad
I'm not saying I wouldn't bang a major
problem
we know passy come on passy would
probably [__] that girl with the reality
show pessie would [__] that guy with the
reality show are you kidding me the 20
year old that's stuck in an
eight-year-old's body oh God no no
um that you wouldn't do that you what's
oh God no you know what's so funny about
that I actually had pulled some of that
for prep that's actually a weird debate
too because everyone's like give me some
of that uh on the one side if you're
better right and you're [__] up but on
the other hand [__] up but people do
make that argument of like she is 28 and
deserves to like not live this weird
isolate yes she does
like stairs Hey listen pessie my
argument ain't that I'm trying to [__]
her I just feel bad to you know very few
people kind of [__] her you know I feel
bad too but also I feel worse being seen
with her remember her boyfriend came out
in public with her and it was like oh
man you just that man just ended his
whole career
what was it oh that was uh that we
actually played it uh Sean array Shawna
Ray I'm something Ray I was trying
Shawna Ray oh my god dude this is a this
is member berries part about her is well
the fact that she's in mentioned and she
could never have a normal life yeah yeah
that's pretty funny the fact that she's
been trapped in prison by God himself
into the body of an eight-year-old and
the only and the only bailiff is is a
bunch of pills that she can't reach at
the [__] top of the counter yeah the
only bailiff is a steel jacketed one
okay well like that and unfortunately
and unfortunately she doesn't have the
she doesn't have the finger strength to
pull to to push the Bell
some kind of Rube Goldberg device like
[__] people exactly
pass on to a peaceful death
yeah probably that that's the funniest
part for me what about for you well
that's way funnier now but the funniest
I promise to breakfast
hello this is so sad
with the toaster I think I'm gonna cut
my wrists ah you said the magic word
it's wrists I am starting to realize why
they don't like us peewee's tiny
Adventure
please
tiny short Adventure
yeah this is let's see what she's up to
trying to see season two of I am Shawna
Ray my favorite part is that she smokes
like a chimney to try to look older oh
yeah she has that [__] forearm tattoo
too yeah she constantly has a [__]
cigarette in her hand it's so like her
[__] she shows up the way Bart dressed
when he was a little bit too short to be
radioactive man with like the boots and
holding a little chihuahua with a
striped suit and his hair spiked up
you're playing Skyrim and you get that
[__] up glitch where they put one of
the old ladies heads on a little kid's
body yes
yes you know she's just she's trying to
do anything she can so that people will
try to hook up with her she's smoking
and drinking she's trying to make it
very obvious she's not a kid well or or
just or Drew Barrymore at eight yeah
watching her smokes like watching viral
footage of a Malaysian baby oh God the
fat baby that was smoking remember the
fat baby that would smoke
you know what I just realized too you
know we [__] about how much Rubble
doesn't respect us and this is the show
we did not only the stove this is the
this is the opening monologue oh my God
God she's probably so depressed oh [__]
well that's not true she has a lot of
people to look up to no Fergie she's
compressed
sorry my blind date is four by three can
I get a widescreen one she's not even on
screen yet
how could you tell yeah how could you
how could you see her
merch just did Us in the closet right
now
what
why why did they set up our blind date
at an amusement parks she can't go on
any other rides
oh [__] [__] verse right now in
his head that's what we do everybody
just starts saying dumb [__] and then we
keep talking and talking and throwing
things out there that's how next thing
you know we're making pedophile jokes
about a 26 year old woman who's very
depressed net two very different
Metuchen says do we look like a joke to
you Rumble imagine you have kids with
her and you got to take the kids to
Disney and she's just gotta stand online
and hold all the coats yeah no the
[__] terrible all right me and the
kids are going on there we're going on
this one although renting a stroller is
cheaper than renting a wheelchair
get one of those strollers you get one
of those combo cat baby strollers yes
bring the pet in here put one of those
little hats on her so she's gonna get
too much sun waiting in line for [__]
Space Mountain just pull a Mr Bean put
her on one of those coin operated things
I put like 50 in it and then go go
everyone keeps tapping her head she's 27
when she's waiting in line in dumbo
screen yet
is a 23 year old living in an
eight-year-old's body as a result of
pituitary
there was there was there was a lot of
those on Epstein Island
dwarfism so the show gives you a glimpse
inside her struggles and her triumphs
but she talked what are her triumphs I
need to I'm not trying to be mean but
what are her triumphs she looks like a
rejected Mario Kart character I mean I'm
getting stronger
she's the guy who [__] American Dad
I'm getting stronger
Royce her triumphs this morning she
reached the eggs didn't break one oh wow
good for her wow that's the price they
are right now she breaks one I'll break
her [__] head Everything Has Changed
me very hard that pituitary gland made
her bones very brittle that literally
would be like killing a child merch
all right let's go carving a child let's
go back to this uh let's go back to this
human Snapchat filter
my life has changed drastically I'll
walk down the streets of New York City
and then this show is actually really
bizarre when you watch it exactly it's
just because
she really does look and sound like a
little kid which the way she talks it's
just it's it's like really if you watch
it it's just jarring because she's
talking about adult [__] like not sexual
just adult everyday [__] like going to
work and paying taxes no but you smoking
a cigarette but you know what but even
even but even dating like dude okay bit
aside just for a quick second do I feel
bad for her of course I feel bad for her
because any dude she dates is gonna be a
creep like there's no way around it
right dude describing this show
literally sounds like a pedophile
defending himself
kid but she carries herself like a woman
because I was trying to find a gentle
way there's no gentle way to put it
there's no way Jack there's no gentle
way to put it without me putting on a
watchless merch I think they're doing
this to like normalize this [__] no
they're doing this so that the Nielsen
company can [__] get all the people
that watch it and put them in the
[__] put them under the jail
you got this you got MILF Manor where's
the middle oh
holy [__] this is this is insane Royce
your joke is premised on the fact that
we actually lock up pedophiles in this
country oh now you're right but fair
enough
yeah
files in this country we put him in the
[__] White House
Hail to the Chief
um wait Taft was a pedophile yes hey
I'll pre hey let me say something to you
uh presidents
I like how it hasn't changed a hundred
percent I've had kids hit on me
I mean yeah obviously kids hit on you
you look like you're wait is she also
dating hold on is she dating a baby
firefighter what's going on what's this
what is this guy who's this guy is that
her thing
AP firefighter what is this this season
on child firefighter they're trying to
do a crossover to get the ratings up wow
Rescue Me junior is not that great baby
firefighter on the makers of cop
toddlers
[Laughter]
he looks like he came out of a fire
truck playset right after right after
adolescent attorneys
[Laughter]
a Lego firefighter today
you need 30 of them to operate the hose
or they go flying all over the [__]
wow
that is the [__] noise
yeah I uh never experienced that what it
sounds like a weird baby firefighter he
is a baby firefighter but again imagine
how does he pass the carrying a body out
of a building test that they all have to
do
I wanted to go on a date with a guy that
looks like [__] Randy Orton that
would be funny I would like people to
see that I'm being vulnerable don't play
Tetris music you'll have all of
munchkinland Maddie
ma'am you're always vulnerable at any
point I could punt kick you nobody can
return kick but I want you you know what
I mean like I actually [__] punt you
like kick you like a [__] punter
across the field you're You're
vulnerable to everything no but like
here's the thing okay You're vulnerable
to a strong gust of wind but think think
about like the little things right well
not her God damn it okay think about the
how do I think about the things that you
don't think about when you're in a
relationship or you're dating a chick
right
you know you're out you're there and you
know sometimes you put your hand on her
back once you put your hand on your leg
nothing like not like you're [__] or
anything but you're like normal like
relationship stuff when you're out right
holding hands for example
imagine being at like a bar setting
right no a crowded theater oh yes it
starts rubbing her legs she starts
rubbing her legs and then it was you
realize it I don't next time no matter
how much he wants to watch the Pixar
movie you're gonna say no because
there's no way for it not to look like
you're bringing your daughter in there
she starts rubbing her crotch stirring
up you're like please not here it's
weird you're not here you know what as a
matter of fact not anywhere please you
remember last time come on man that was
the weirdest experience I've ever had at
a Dave and Busters
no she would make a great pedo decoy
though oh dude that should be her job we
should hook her up with Alex Rosenberg
could you imagine yeah that would be a
weird looking couple Oh you mean like no
standing at three foot ten Shauna
continues to share her journey living
with pituitary dwarfism a condition
brought on by brain cancer at six months
old
[__] man we're having fun I know that
was why did you ruin this for us so
cancer can be fun look at him I thought
we took the L out of TLC what are we
doing here no yeah you're right you're
right okay let's stop this is a channel
no we're done now okay
let's call it the channel yeah the
channel what do you know we spent some
time with Shawna Renee and now we feel
dirty great like everyone else that
watches wow I mean perfect it's actually
perfect the way that worked out it's
funny because the people that actually
watch that show only wants like the
first 15 minutes of it and then stop
abruptly see I only watch it to feel
badly because it's one of the only
channels that comes in
foreign